this video is brought to you by skill
share an online learning community for
creators with thousands of classes in
design business and more two months free
trial for our viewers there is a link
below more on them in a bit imagine
you're in charge of sending a culture
bearing probe off into space one capable
of carrying a single example of 20th
century art what would you pick to
represent us some great novel perhaps or
would you pick a slender volume based on
a radio show a volume emblazoned with
the words don't panic a volume that
contains everything from the precise
reason you should always carry a towel
to how to mix the most powerful drink in
the universe we're talking of course
about The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy perhaps one of the most unique
pieces of sci-fi ever written and the
author behind the book we here at Baia
graphics would send as our emissary to
the stars well that would be Douglas
Adams born in the 1950s Adams was the
products of a post-war Britain exploding
with creativity it was the era of the
Beatles Pink Floyd Monty Python and
Doctor Who yes even in this intensely
vibrant age Adams still managed to dream
up a universe so unique it has arguably
never been equaled in the video today
with thumbing a ride into the past to
explore the life of the man behind a
literary legend
[Music]
far out in the Uncharted back waters of
the unfashionable end of the western
spiral arm of the galaxy lies a small
unregarded yellow Sun it was on a planet
orbiting this unregarded Sun thus in the
year 1952 Douglas nor Adams was born
later in life Adams liked to joke that
he was the first DNA in Cambridge having
been born there several months before
Watson and Crick discovered the far more
famous version but aside from raising a
smile that gag may have served to hide
painful memories the family Douglas
Adams was born into was both deeply
eccentric and deeply fractured a lot of
this fracturing came courtesy of the
boy's father Christopher Douglas Adams a
bombastic giant of a man with a
personality the size of Canada
Christopher was a man who loved booze
cars and women you'll notice that's
women rural not women singular which may
be why the Adams household regularly
radiated misery before Adams was even
five his parents are divorced and Syd
gone to live with his mother's parents
well actually make that her parents and
their animals Adams his maternal
grandmother was an animal lover par
excellence and the house was overrun
with stray dogs stray cats stray badgers
and anything else that might conceivably
eat your food and poo everywhere perhaps
it was due to the endless clamor in the
house but Adams became so introverted at
school that his teachers thought that he
might be mentally subnormal but while
the boy had a weird unhappy childhood he
never suffered financially not long
after ditching his family Christopher
Adams had managed to seduce an
incredibly wealthy widow who paid for
Adams to have a private education thus
it was that age 11 the boy was
dispatched to the elite Brentwood
boarding school for Adams Brentwood was
the first time he ever felt his oddness
was appreciated not yet 12 Adams was
already a six foot giant and would
continue to grow until he hit six foot
five on top of that it inherited both
his father's gigantic personality and
his gigantic nose making him both a
natural performer and instantly
recognizable this translated easily into
performing in school plays where Adams
became renowned for his bizarre sense of
humor not that it was really his sense
of humor though in nineteen
69 the first season of Monty Python's
Flying Circus had exploded the BBC like
a particularly silly stick of dynamite
like everyone else is aged Adams had
fallen in love with the troupe but while
most kids wanted to watch the Pythons
Addams wanted to be them as he later
commented I wanted to be John Cleese it
took me some time to realize that job
was taken but it wasn't just Monty
Python that had gripped Adams
imagination Britain in 1969
was in the midst of a full-blown
cultural explosion there was pythons
comedy The Beatles music Doctor Who's
sci-fi wanderings with a talent as
distinct as atoms as it's tempting to
think that he just sprang from nowhere
but no his was a sense of humor born
from a particular moment in British
history but while all the ingredients
for his greatest work were there in the
air in the 1960s they only coalesced
together thanks to pure chance
in the summer of 1971 Adams was
travelling around Europe before
finishing Brentwood and starting at
Cambridge University as the legend goes
he found himself at some points lying
dead drunk in a field in Austria
contemplating alternately his
Hitchhiker's Guide to Europe hands the
Stars spinning above him just before he
lost consciousness
the drunken teenager had a thought that
would change his life he decided that
someone should write a Hitchhiker's
Guide not to another continent but to
the galaxy if it was overindulgence in
alcohol that gave Adams is great idea it
was also likely alcohol that stopped him
from doing anything with it by 1974 or
Adams had graduated Cambridge after
student years in which she did heroic
leader to work and heroically huge about
some drinking now he was living in
London still drinking heroic amounts but
doing nothing except writing the odd
sketch that the BBC would immediately
reject but while the boozy London Life
was keeping Adams from his art it was
also going to give him his bug back that
same year Adams was introduced to Graham
Chapman if that name sounds familiar is
because Chapman was the fabled straight
man of Monty Python straits in the
comedic sense as Chapman was actually
openly gay he was also a man who liked
to drink and liked others who
also likes to drink and in adams he
seemed to have finally found the perfect
drinking buddy throughout the year the
two met up to imbibe indescribable
quantities of alcohol the more often
they met the more Chapman became
convinced Adams had a talent for sketch
comedy so he gave him a spot on the
biggest sketch show on earth on December
the 5th 1974 Douglas Adams became one of
only two non members to have ever
written for Monty Python his sketch
patient abuse features Chapman as a
doctor who forces a heavily bleeding
Terry Jones to fill out endless inane
forms before he'll give him any
treatments it's a classic Adams riff on
bureaucracy albeit one tooled Python's
specific brand of humor
it was also successful enough that
Chapman asked Adams to keep writing with
him after Python ended in 1975 the two
made a pilot for a sketch show called
out of the trees we don't need to go
into trees too much though new one
episode was ever made and as Adams once
said it had some good bits but it wasn't
really that good
still it's worth noting the one big
sketch Adams contributed at the end of
the episode a young couple pick a flower
off a bush this causes a chain reaction
of events which begins with the police
being called out progresses to the whole
of Europe going to war and ends with the
complete destruction of the world from
that point on Armageddon would be a
subject that obsessed the young writer
when out of the trees failed Chapman
ditched his new writing partner drifting
back to pythons surreal embrace although
Adams would contribute a couple of
one-liners to Monty Python and the Holy
Grail that was really it for his sketch
writing career depressed Adams returned
to his mum's house over the next year
1976 he continued to try his hand at
writing and performing worse it'll went
nowhere
there was the sketch show he went on
tour with which ran at two hours but
only contained one good gag there was
the pilot series he wrote with the
friends about a pair of astronomers who
discover the world is going to be
destroyed to make way for an
interstellar advertising sign that the
BBC refused to touch there was even a
spec script he sent to the Doctor Who
production office one about the doctor
becoming trapped on a ship crewed
entirely by the useless people of
society but while the doctor who team
liked the idea they didn't pick it up
come Christmas 1976 Adams was trapped at
his mum's places career dead in the
water and
he was on the verge of giving up at that
moment it must have seemed to him like
1977 would bring nothing but more
disappointment and more bad news well
buckle up because Adams is about to be
proven very wrong
the next 12 months are gonna hit the
young man like a black ship diving into
the heart of a son on a dismal February
day in 1977 Adams made a trip to London
to have lunch with the BBC's light
entertainment producer it had been a
month since Adams as depressing
Christmas and paid writing work was
still out of reach that all changed that
fateful day as the two ate the producer
happens mentioned that he wanted a
sci-fi comedy series for Radio four he
wondered aloud if Adams might like to
try as hand at a pilot episode and just
like that badams was a writer again
Adams initial pitch was the ends of the
earth a six-part comedy series in which
every episode would end with the earth
blowing up but as he was writing the
pilots in which earth is demolished to
make way for a hyperspace bypass Adams
decided he needed to give his alien
character Ford Prefect a job at last
bad idea he had had long ago lying drunk
in a field in Austria came back to him
Ford Prefect would be a researcher for
the Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
from that moment the concepts of ends of
the earth went out of the window
replaced by a series about Ford Prefect
the guide he was researching and his
human pal Arthur Dent by March the pilot
episode for The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy was ready to go the BBC gave
her the green light that dream the cast
assembled in London to record the
episode it didn't take long and while
that should have been that but something
had changed in Douglas Adams Zeo had
come over him since it decided what his
radio show was going to be about no
longer did Adams simply want to make a
radio comedy he wanted to make something
unlike anything anyone had ever heard
before a sci-fi show with production
levels Pink Floyd would envy for the
rest of that summer Adams and his
producer tinkered away in the booth
creating the sci-fi soundscape for their
show they spent as long on single sound
effects as some radio shows dudes on an
entire series
but it was worth it by fall the pilot
was being circulated around the BBC
everyone loved it as winter approached
Adams was cooled into two very important
meetings the first was with the Doctor
Who team who'd heard his pilot and now
wanted him to write a four-part episode
the second was with Radio 4 they wanted
to Commission a full series of
hitchhikers naturally Adam said yes to
both of them this would become a pattern
in Adams life taking on so much work he
became trapped in permanent panic mode
barely able to finish by the deadline in
the future this would become a crippling
problem that severely limited his output
bus in 1977 Adams was still young and
still just able to get things done
although it was touch-and-go the biggest
problem was the while Adams had a tone
and ideas for hitchhikers he didn't have
a story so inventing a plot on the fly
became harder and harder things got so
bad that Adams would be forced to finish
episodes inside the booth as the cast
were recording around him when that
didn't work he had to bring in his
friends to help him finish still finish
them he did at 10:30 p.m. on March the
8th 1978 the first episode of
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy was
broadcast on radio 4 as it went out
Adams presumably clutched his towel and
hoped that it would be successful but
even in his wildest fantasies he
couldn't have foreseen how successful it
would become but now just before we get
into that huge success I want to take a
moment to tell you about today's sponsor
Skillshare now maybe you've thought that
one day you'd like to write a book maybe
even a great book well a great way to
learn how to do that is with Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators and they have
thousands of classes in design business
and much more done like some websites
where you have to pay for individual
courses with a premium membership from
Skillshare you get unlimited access so
you can take as many classes as you want
specific to writing they have a great
course by daniel jose alder he's a New
York Times bestselling author and he
covers the essentials of writing in a
class called storytelling 101 character
conflict context craft it's a great
watch if you want to learn how to write
but there's also loads of other great
classes on writing on Skillshare and
well there's also classes on pretty much
everything else
it's January so make twenty twenty year
where you explore new skills deepen
existing passions and get lost in
creativity with skill shares online
classes anyway join more than 7 million
creators learning with skill share skill
share is giving away two three months of
premium membership to help you explore
your creativity if you click the link in
the description below and after that
it's only around ten dollars a month and
let's get back to today's video Adams
would like to say of hitchhikers sudden
success that it was like being
helicoptered to the top of Mount Everest
or having an orgasm without the foreplay
people loved us major newspapers raved
about it people flooded the post office
with letters addressed to the guide
itself if you're new to the work of
Douglas Adams you may be wondering what
made people quite so obsessed with
hitchhikers here was a show in which the
basic plot was that the earth was
destroyed and now the alien guidebook
researcher Ford and his human friends
Arthur was stuck traipsing around the
galaxy but the genius of hitchhikers
doesn't lie in the plot but in the comic
concepts that show carelessly
throughout by the dozens each clever
enough to make a series in its own right
there's this supercomputer deep thought
which spends centuries calculating the
meaning of life the universe and
everything only two solemnly report that
the answer is 42 there's the Android
Marvin who is created with a brain so
big he can conceive of the futility of
his existence and spends the series in a
state of terminal depression there are
time-traveling Chesterfield sofas a bowl
of petunias that last thought before
plummeting out of space and shattering
on a planet is oh no not again
and a spaceship crewed entirely by the
most useless members of society yes that
last one is the same idea Douglas Adams
pitch to dr. who cannibalizing his own
work would soon become a core part of
Adams method by April 1978 hitchhiker's
was a British sensation the book was
swiftly commissioned for Adams to write
along with a second radio series it was
enough work for any aspiring writer but
Adams wasn't just any aspiring writer he
was a madman with an attraction to
impossible workloads which may be why
Adams agreed to also take on the job of
script editing Doctor Who although it's
overshadowed by hitchhikers Adam
doctor who is semi-legendary Adams took
on the job out of fondness of the show
and a mistaken belief that it wouldn't
be too demanding instead he found
himself working on a show where veteran
writers would write a four-page
treatment for a four part serial handed
to the script editor and tell him to
turn it into two hours of television
this meant that Adams was not only doing
the work of ten people but also handling
rewrites on top of that but it also
meant a year of Doctor Who filled with
hitchhikers style inspiration the
highlights of this was city of death a
four-part story set in Paris where the
doctor steals the Mona Lisa meets
Leonardo da Vinci shares a scene with
John Cleese and
accidentally creates all life on earth
it's a fun joyful hilarious bit of TV
and it was written in a single panic and
alcohol-fueled weekend when the original
writer dropped out at the last second
leaving Adams to just pick up the pieces
incredible a city of death was though it
severely restricted Adams as time for
working on hitchhikers by early 1979
Adams was in a catastrophic state of
procrastination on the book adaptation
with almost nothing written finally as
the deadline swept by his editor just
told him to finish whatever page he was
on and hand the damn thing over with a
third of the original season still
unadapted Adams meekly complied book one
of the hitchhikers trilogy was published
in September 1979 it immediately shot to
the top of the bestseller lists aged
only 27 Adams was now at the head of a
bonafide phenomenon now all he needed to
do was make sure that it didn't go to
his head
[Applause]
[Music]
the 1980s began in a whirlwind of
success for Adams there's the rest of
Britain embraced the Thatcher era
reluctantly or otherwise hitchhikers
season two went out on the radio
followed by the seconds booked the
restaurant at the end of the universe
and then a BAFTA winning BBC TV
adaptation with all of this exposure
came what's every struggling writer
always craves money lots and lots of
money by 1981 Adams was a seriously
wealthy guy he began channeling his
father's spirit blowing cash on cars
girls meals music and computers yes
computers one of the reasons companies
like Google program Hitchhiker's Easter
eggs into their search engine is because
Adams was a hugely influential writer on
technology he was one of the first
grasped what the coming information age
would mean and toward the u.s. giving
witty knowledgeable lectures on the
subject but while this on him legions of
fans in Silicon Valley writing was still
his bread and butter and Adams was
starting to find it harder and harder
when the time came to write the third
Hitchhiker's book Adams simply
cannibalized one of his old unproduced
scripts for Doctor Who and so it was
that Doctor Who and the Cricut men
became life the universe and everything
by the time the fourth book in the
increasingly inaccurately named trilogy
came out in 1984 Adams could barely
stand to be with his own creation to be
honest I really shouldn't have written
it he later said and I felt that when I
was writing it I did the best I could
but it wasn't you know really from the
heart but even as his chronic
procrastination began to turn into
fully-fledged writer's block Adams as
Locke kept right on going at the start
of the decade he met his future wife
Jane Elizabeth Belson he also met an
absurd number of famous people
before long Adams and Belson's house in
Islington was throwing parties where you
could bump into anyone from John Cleese
to Stephen Fry to Richard Dawkins and
yes that would be that same Richard
Dawkins Adams described himself as a
radical atheist and was naturally
besties with the scientist but perhaps
the coolest people Adams befriended were
Pink Floyd there are legends that
halfway through his parties Adams would
hand out guitars and treat the crowds to
an impromptu Pink Floyd gig but even as
Adam star rose he was
beginning to discover just how ephemeral
this shiny world was in 1985 atoms were
sent alongside zoologist mark car
wouldn't Madagascar to write an article
about endangered animals for the
observer the two hit it off and a couple
of years later they did a radio series
together about endangered species it was
a show that would change atoms as life
the show and it's book last chance to
see was atoms as personal wake-up call
to the damage that humans were doing to
their environment in the aftermath he
would become one of the earliest loudest
voices on conservation and the dangers
posed by habitat destruction still the
1980s ended on a relatively good note
Adams managed to get over his writer's
block long enough to write to Dirk
Gently detective stories one of which
again cannibalized his old Doctor Who
scripts in 1991 he finally married Jane
Elizabeth Belson at the start of the
1990s Adams was in his late 30s he was
world famous rich and married to the
woman of his dreams if this kept up who
knew what the rest of his life would be
like
unfortunately we here in the future
already know the tragic answer douglas
adams may not have yet been 40 but he
was already entering the final decade of
his life
[Music]
the last 10 years of Adams as life dawns
with the writer in a bleak place after
nearly seven years had agreed to write
the fifth hitchhikers book on the
understanding that it would be the last
even so his writer's block crippled him
there would be nothing for weeks on end
nothing but Adams locked away in hotels
by his grim-faced editor staring at the
ceiling we heard tales that the
publisher hired a fleet of writers to
sit downstairs churning out chapters
based on Adams as outline until Adams
was finally roused to work by the
thought of all those other writers doing
his book wrong mostly harmless was
released in 1992 there was without a
doubt the bleakest thing Adams ever
roasts with a downer ending that leaves
a nasty taste in the mouth much later
Adams would claim had been seriously
depressed while writing it and while it
really shows still life moves fast and
within a couple of years of the gloomy
conclusion of hitchhikers Adams seemed
to be living life to the full again for
his 42nd birthday in 1994 for example he
was invited on stage by Pink Floyd to
play a gig with him later that same year
his daughter Polly Jane rocket Adams was
born by the 21st century Adams was
lecturing in Silicon Valley developing
video games with his production company
and working on turning hitchhikers into
a Hollywood movie it even started
writing again tentatively putting
together ten chapters of a third Dirk
Gently book that he thought might even
become the sixth hitchhikers book and
then it happens the moments the moments
as shocking to his fandom as the site of
a Vogon constructor fleet hanging in the
air in much the same way that bricks
don't on May the 11th 2001 Douglas Adams
suffered a massive heart attack at his
local gym at the time he died he wasn't
even 50 in the wake of Adams as death
tributes poured in from around the world
this wasn't just the regular sadness we
feel when someone passes away this was a
keenly felt pain almost personal like
that felt when John Lennon or David
Bowie died as Stephen Fry later noted
hitchhikers had been sci-fi on a human
scale it resonated with people made it
feel like Adams was talking to them and
them alone and that may be why his death
devastated so many people but what
should we make today of Douglas Adams
what should we make of the man who wrote
a handful of slim comic volumes before
vanishing into the abyss well it depends
on your perspective right now it's still
too early to tell what atoms as
long-term impacts on fiction will be
Wally has endless admirers there's a
sense that his work was maybe too unique
a dead ends for any writer who doesn't
happen to be a comic genius on the other
hand Adams at influence is already
everywhere we mentioned earlier that
Adams was an early adopter of
environmentalism of computers of ideas
and part of his charm was his ability to
take those ideas and explain them simply
in ways that still impact the ways his
readers think as Neil Gaiman said in
I think perhaps what Douglass was was a
futurologist or an explainer one day
maybe we'll realize that the most
important job there is is someone who
can explain the world to itself in ways
the world can't forget the continents
may grow old and die the world may be
demolished to make way for a hyperspace
bypass but somewhere out there in the
cosmos some life form will always be sat
in a restaurant at the end of the
universe
reading in wide-eyed wonder as Douglas
Adams explains the world to it and that
life form will be smiling so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe also please do check out our
fantastic sponsor Skillshare I'm linking
to them below and thank you for watching
[Music]